So Donald Trump did another rally last night.
This one was in Pennsylvania, where Donald
Trump is now losing to Joe Biden by an average
of seven points.
And Donald Trump actually asked women to like
him during yesterday's rally.
We will get to that.
But let's start in order piece by piece.
Donald Trump kicking off the rally by slamming
Joe Biden because Joe Biden abandoned Pennsylvania
when he was 10 years old.
How do you lose to a guy like this?
This was never come to Pennsylvania.
Again, I love this.
They say he was born in Scranton, but he left.
He left, he abandoned you.
Give me a break.
This would be like attacking me for abandoning
Argentina when I was five.
As if at age five, I could have said, thanks,
mom and dad, I'm gonna stick around here instead
of moving to the United States with you.
A really strange line of attack.
But nothing matters to these crowds.
They will cheer anything.
This next one I love.
I don't know if you guys have seen, but Pete
Bhoot, Edge Edge or Buddy Judge has been on
Fox News a lot lately, crushing, crushing
Trump.
So Trump apparently doesn't like it.
And he talked about Pete Boota, judge, at
yesterday's rally.
Except he called them budy check, which is
different.
You had Alfred E. Neuman.
You had all these people.
You know who Alfred it.
Yes.
People to check Pete Bodycheck.
He was a bad mayor of a failed town and he's
going to run for president.
You know, just just wild stuff.
I mean, it's insane that this is the reality
we live in.
And then here's that strangest moment of the
entire thing.
When Donald Trump asked suburban women to
like him, a sort of Jeb Bush, please clap
a moment, accept much more Cringely.
This was after about 90 seconds of ranting
incoherently.
I don't want to give low income housing next
to your house.
Okay.
That's OK.
And I ended the regulation, the rule that
made the zoning so impossible that you had
to destroy your communities.
And then I hear that the suburban woman.
I think that this suburban woman and I used
to say a suburban housewife, I used to take
heat, but I said, does anybody care?
Do you care?
My sister will go, No.
Again, the only one cares as them, Trump said,
suburban housewife.
But I didn't say it because I don't.
You learn very quickly.
But suburban women, they should like me more
than anybody here tonight because I ended
deregulation that destroyed your neighborhood.
I ended the regulation that brought crime
to the suburbs.
And you're going to live the American dream.
And that's what you're going to do.
And remember this.
Twenty nine percent of the people experiencing
the American dream in the suburbs happened
to be minority.
And you don't know that.
But twenty nine percent.
And we're doing this for everybody.
We're not doing it one way or the other.
We're doing it.
And I ended it.
They said, sir, we can amend it.
I said, I don't want to admit that.
I want to end it.
It was a horror show.
And this loser, Corey Booker, is the guy that's
going to be in charge of the program.
The guy's a stone cold loser.
One person, he got one percent.
He ran.
He was going to be great.
You know, one percent every week.
He was like her.
Down, down, down.
They should have picked him.
But no, he'll be in charge of your suburban.
So can I ask you to do me a favor?
Suburban women, would you please like me?
Is that a message of hope and change or what.
Right.
Suburban women please like me that you may
want to workshop that messaging to women a
little bit.
It could probably get you.
You might want to focus group that a little
bit before you commit to women.
Please like me.
Then Donald Trump again pulling out this line
that he is now immune to reinfection from
Corona virus and wants to kiss all the men
and women in the audience.
Let's take a look at this next clip.
And now I'm immune.
They tell me I'm immune.
I could come down and start kissing everybody.
I'll kiss every guy, man and woman, man and
woman.
Look at that guy.
How handsome me kiss him.
Not not with a lot of enjoyment, but that's
OK.
Joe Biden would terminate our recovery, delay
the vaccine.
One of the funniest things about Donald Trump's
rallies is you can tell from his tone when
he's kind of riffing and when he's on the
teleprompter.
And sometimes the contrast is so stark when
he goes from riffing back to the prompter,
which, by the way, he did it there.
He he slams Biden all the time for using a
teleprompter, Trump using one as well.
It's almost jarring when Trump gets back on
the prompter because it's like two different
speeches woven together in a bizarre amalgam
of insanity.
Trump then asked the crowd, how many of you
have had Corona virus?
Now, this is if only for a few reasons.
First of all, he congratulated them for being
immune, which, as you all know, there are
still questions about reinfection, how long
immunity lasts, et cetera.
Not particularly responsible for Trump to
go head first on this.
But, you know, when you have people crowded
together during a pandemic asking the infected
folks, even if it's previous, I mean, who
really knows when when they last had it or
would have tested positive asking people to
raise their hands to say, I had corona virus.
You're not going to get a lot of takers, I
don't think.
But regardless, Trump tries to take a look
hard.
The FDA has been great to everyone.
Fighting to recover from the virus.
I feel your pain because I felt your pain.
And we will beat this virus together.
And for those who has had it, who has had
it here, who's had it?
Yeah, a lot of people.
A lot of people.
Other people I want to say hello to because
you are right now immune.
You're right now immune.
Or they say that, you know, they hate to admit
it because I had it, not how I would try to
get a crowd fired up by having those masks
together who have had Corona virus put their
hands up and say, yeah, I had it not not exactly
making people feel too good.
And then Donald Trump wrapping up with this
prepackaged piece of his stump speech that
he's been using a lot now.
And the crowd just loves it.
They shouldn't under God.
And together with the incredible people of
Pennsylvania, we have made America wealthy
again.
We have made America strong again.
We have made God proud again.
And we will make us safe again.
And we will make America great again.
Thank you very much, Pennsylvania.
Thank you.
Get out and vote.
Vote, vote.
Vote.
Completely and utterly surreal events.
We hopefully are down to the last three weeks
of Trump rallies we will ever have and then
done zo.
If we vote, if we if we get it done tonight,
7:00 p.m. Eastern, Trump will be in Iowa.
I will be live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
I hope you'll join me for audience participation
and live commentary.
If not, I understand.
I really do.
And hopefully we're down to the last three
weeks of this